[Musique]
bonsoir à tous alors moi dans la vie
j'ai une passion ça aurait très bien pu
être de la danse ou du tennis mais je
pense que vous le savez déjà
moi je fais de la voile vous allez me
dire c'est plutôt bateau pour une
rochelaise
sauf que moi à 15 ans je me suis
retrouvé là alors l'histoire je vous
racontais commence tout simplement dans
une voiture
j'étais avec mon frère et mon père sur
le retour de l'entraînement et je leur
disais moi quand je serai grande je
ferai quelque chose d'incroyable
n'importe quoi je ferai le tour du monde
à la voile
la traversée de l'atlantique je sais que
je veux vivre ça et puis avec mon prêt
ans et 10 mai mais pourquoi attendre
d'être grand pourquoi pas maintenant
avec mes propres moyens
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque je faisais
de l'optimist l'optimiste est ce bateau
là ça fait pas plus de deux mètres 30
ça s'appelle une baignoire dans le
jargon c'est ça se remplit d'eau en
permanence et puis il faut surtout
savoir que ça n'avance pas alors je me
suis dit mais qu'est ce que je peux
faire avec mon optimiste d'incroyable
mais de réalisable
je me suis retrouvée un an plus tard à
traverser la manche en optimist traversé
la main
son optimisme ça représente 75 miles ce
pardon ça représente soixante quinze
mille 15 heures de navigation je me suis
levé à 3 heures du matin 2 je suis
partie de l'île de wight et je suis
arrivé jusqu'à cherbourg à 19 heures ça
a été une expérience juste
extraordinaire
je pense que que ce qui m'a le plus
marqué c'est toutes les émotions que
j'ai traversés il ya d'abord eu le matin
je pense que ça soit ma tête
l'angoissé la peur je me suis réveillé
il y avait du vent dans le port et là je
me suis dit c'est aujourd'hui c'est
maintenant j'ai plus le choix il faut
que j'y aille
et puis après ça s'est inversé j'ai
commencé à m'habiller à préparer le
bateau et là je me suis dit ouais c'est
aujourd'hui mais en fait ça fait un an
que j'attends ça et j'ai trois très
envie d'y aller après j'étais déterminé
encore une fois ça se voit ma tête
avrillé eu je pense la meilleure partie
de cette aventure c'était la navigation
de nuit
je me souviens j'étais avec tout mon art
hirai de sécurité la balise gps la vhf
j'avais ma petite lampe torche et je me
souviens je voyais rien du tout j'ai
éclairé juste la vague de devant et je
me guidait avec la lune
c'était incroyable parce que je me
sentais vivre je me sentais aventurière
et puis après il ya eu aussi le lever du
soleil
ce moment mais juste magique toute façon
le loreur sur l'eau c'est toujours
unique et magnifique et là franchement
j'ai pas été déçu
derrière moi je commençais à voir
disparaître l'île de wight est devant
moi je croise le premier cargo
un cargo c c'est impressionnant
c'est un immeuble de 300 mètres qui est
posé sur l'eau qu'on ne peut pas arrêter
et moi j'étais là tout petit à côté
et puis après il ya eu aussi des moments
difficiles au milieu de la traversée de
la manche commence à y avoir beaucoup de
vent et beaucoup de vagues et à ce
moment là jean fournes deux fois de
suite
enfourner c'est à dire que l'avant du
bateau plantes dans l'eau et une énorme
vague qui le remplit il se trouve
immergé et sa baisse au niveau de l'eau
est à ce moment là je me suis dit mais
ça m'arrive comme ça pendant 15 heures
ça va être vraiment très long mais j'ai
vu ça comme un juste une petite épreuve
à passer et je me souviens je me suis
levé j'ai pris mes deux écoles et j'ai
écopé le plus rapidement possible parce
que les vagues re remplissez le bateau
et après j'étais très fier de moi et je
me suis dit je me concentre bien sûr la
vague maintenant puis après 15 heures de
navigation 15 heures à passer à être
concentré sur la vague de devant et en
même temps à capter mais chaque instant
si je voulais pas oublié ce à quoi je
voulais je voulais me souvenir de tout
tous les détails
donc après 15 heures j'étais fatigué
mais enfin j'arrive et puis là mais
quelle joie
déjà je retrouve ma famille je retrouve
mes amis s'étaient voilages et j'étais
super fier de moi je pouvais me dire
j'ai réalisé mon rêve un rêve que je
préparais depuis un an je les fais cette
traversée de la manche a été comme un
déclic je me suis dit en fait j'ai enfin
compris ce qu'ils ont rendue heureuse ce
qui me rend heureuse c'est de réaliser
des rêves comme ça de partir de réaliser
d aventure pareille et donc je me suis
dit je vais écrire la suite de cette
histoire est un an plus tard je suis
parti faire la traversée du détroit de
gibraltar en optimist toujours cette
traversée a été beaucoup plus difficile
au niveau de la préparation et de la
logistique
déjà parce que c'est un endroit où la
météo est très durable à prévoir et puis
aussi parce que c'est un endroit assez
dangereux puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
trafic
mais au niveau physique et sportif ça a
été beaucoup plus simple j'ai navigué
que cinq heures et ce qui s'est passé
juste avant l'arrivée c'est que j'ai
pleuré sur le bateau j'étais pas fier de
mon fait
j'étais déçu parce que j'avais pas
réaliser mon rêve qui était de partir
plus loin de 2 voilà de dépasser mes
limites partir
me retrouver perdu au milieu de nulle
part au milieu de l'océan et devoir me
débrouiller avec mes propres moyens et
je n'avais pas vécu ça donc j'étais déçu
mais ça a été comme un mal pour un bien
puisque le soir je me souviens alors
déjà j'étais dans une période où il
fallait que je prenne un choix pour mon
futur soit partir vers les jeux
olympiques soit partir vers la course au
large et le soir j'ai dit à mon père ça
y est je sais moi je veux partir vers la
course au large
je veux aller plus loin je veux dépasser
mes limites pourquoi ce qui se passe au
fond de moi en fait à chaque fois que je
pars au large
à chaque fois que je dépasse mes limites
et que je me sens aventurière c'est que
je ressens la même chose
je ressens une sorte de deux boules
d'adrénaline tout simplement une boule
d'énergie juste là et ça me procure va
une boule de bonheur au final ça fait
dix ans que je fais de la sophrologie et
je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je
travaille ça pour en faire un point
d'ancrage et une force pour construire
mais mai prochain mes prochains projets
est donc lié avec les techniques de
sophrologie j'ai visualisé 7 ce ressenti
déjà j'ai associé sur un senti à une
rose pour moi c'est un symbole après je
lui aussi associé à un geste signal
j'appuie fort au creux de la main et ça
me permet de le réactiver
et donc ce qui se passe c'est que tous
les jours je me pose je prends du recul
un peu sur mon rythme de vie qui est
parfois un peu freiné et simplement je
me dis mais qu'est ce qui me fait vibrer
quel est mon inspiration quel est mon
prochain rêve
quel est mon prochain projet ou défi
qu'elle faisait le sens de ma vie au
final et ça me permet d'avoir toujours
cette force avec moi est de savoir où je
vais mon prochain projet qu'est ce que
c'est
je veux
traverser l'atlantique en solitaire soit
un bateau qui fait 6 mètres 50
ça s'appelle la mini transat c'est une
course sans assistance avec aucun
contact avec la terre est très peu
d'électronique
je me lance là dedans j'ai reçu mon
bateau il ya quelques mois donc vraiment
je suis débutante
j'ai jamais fait de course au large et
parfois je me dis mais je vais jamais y
arriver c'est pas pour moi où j'en suis
pas capable
et puis il ya pas très longtemps j'ai
enfin compris le vrai danger qui de
tomber dans l'eau c'est tout simple j'ai
je sais pas j'ai fait comme une
connexion je me suis imaginé sur mon
bateau comme si j'étais sur le haut
d'une falaise
et si jamais je tombé dans l'eau il ya
autant de chances de survie je me suis
imaginé ça alors ça ça m'a fait de l'
angoisse de la peur mais au final je
sais que ça va pas mr masse
je sais que ça va pas m'arrêter je sais
que je vais continuer à avancer avancer
avancer parce que je vois mon rêve et
qu'il faut simplement que je le
construisent sans sauter les étapes
simplement me concentrant sur ce que
j'ai à faire dans le moment présent
et voilà juste construire mon rêve petit
à petit alors voilà je vous partage mon
expérience je vous partage mon histoire
et ce petit outil qui est ma rose parce
que je pense que c'est possible pour
tout le monde tout le monde peut le
faire
chacun peut réaliser son rêve
je veux vous donner cet espoir de
réaliser votre rêve est ainsi décrire
votre futur merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]